didn't
Minister Joseph honorable members
during my trip to China this month
I was fortunate to be in Beijing on the
day of the Ching Ming Festival one of
the most traditional Chinese holidays
it is a day to honor
and pay respect to past Generations
and it is part of the very rich history
and culture of China that certainly
fascinates and captures the imagination
of people all around the world
seeing this country again firsthand
only reinforced my deep admiration and
respect for the people of China
for centuries they have helped shape
World Civilization and in the last
decades they have really transformed the
economy of their country lifting more
than 800 million people out of poverty
in the last 45 years
we should never lose sight of the
magnitude of this transformation into a
modern day economic Powerhouse
key Global player
and the leader in many of the
cutting-edge technologies that certainly
will shape the next Decades of global
civilization and progress
this International and economic status
as well as our own interests make it all
the more important for Europe to manage
its relations with China
and for me that also shows that
decoupling
is clearly not viable
desirable or even practical for Europe
but as I said back in January and as I
set out in more detail a few weeks ago
there is clearly a need for Europe
to work on de-risking some important and
sensitive parts of our relationship so
de-risking but not decoupling
much has been said about this since I
set out the principles of this
touristing strategy and even more has
been said since the last trip
in many ways that reaction is good
because Europe needs to have this
discussion and so I want first and uh
foremost thank the parliament for
putting this debate on today it's urgent
that it's good that we have this debate
most importantly
I say this because this relationship is
too important for us not to Define our
own European strategy and principles for
engagement with China
I believe we can
and we must carve out our own distinct
European approach
that also leaves space for us to
cooperate with other partners too
and the starting point for this
is the need to have a shared and very
clear eyed picture of the risks and the
opportunities in our engagement with
China
and this means
acknowledging
as well as clearly saying
that the Chinese Communist party's
actions
have now caught up with its stated
Ambitions and the hardening of China's
overall strategic posture over the last
years
for example
the shows of military force in the South
China South China Sea in the East China
Sea and at the border with India
directly affect our partners and their
legitimate interests
or on the issue of Taiwan
the eu's one China policy is
long-standing
we have consistently called for peace
and stability in the Taiwan Strait
and we stand strongly against any
unilateral change of the status quo in
particular by the use of force
[Applause]
we must also never shy away
from talking about the deeply concerning
and Grave human rights violations in
qingyang
and just as China has been ranking up
its military posture it has also ramped
up its policy of Economic and trade
coercion as we've seen from Lithuania to
Australia
and the targeting of everything from pop
bands to trade brands
we have also seen these tactics directed
right here in the house of European
democracy
and I want to express my solidarity to
those members of the European Parliament
who have been unfairly sanctioned by the
Chinese Communist party just for calling
out human right violations
and all this is symptomatic for the fact
that China has now turned the page
on the era of reform and opening
and is moving into a new era of security
and control
I heard this in Beijing from many
European companies
who have witnessed firsthand this shift
towards security and away from the logic
of open markets and free trade
and to strengthen that security and
control Leverage
China is openly pursuing a policy of
reducing its dependency on the world
that's completely okay that's their
right but while increasing the world's
dependency on itself
you know the examples for example
whether it's on critical raw materials
or the renewable energy on emerging Tech
like artificial intelligence Quantum
Computing or biotech
honorable members
having this clear-eyed assessment
of the Chinese Communist parties actions
and direction of travel
actually including its relations with
Putin's Russia and its attitude towards
the war in Ukraine
is a prerequisite
for today's discussion
and it will allow us to develop an
approach that is tailored to our
economic and National Security
imperatives
one that we all can rally around
and one that is clearly understood
in Europe
in the world
and crucially also in China itself
and this last point is one of the key
reasons
I felt it was important to make the trip
to Beijing alongside president macron
it was a chance to discuss with
President XI
the shared challenges that we need to
work on together
whether in our bilateral trading
relation
or on global issues like debt relief
climate change and nuclear
non-proliferation
but equally important the trip was
necessary
to ensure that we are as honest and
clear in our messaging in Beijing
as we are in Brussels or here in
strasbok
this is a core part of our efforts to
de-risk through diplomacy
by reducing the space for
misunderstanding and miscommunication
regardless of how difficult the
conversations may be
the point I made in Beijing is
that we do not want to cut economic
societal political and scientific ties
we have many strong links in China's a
vital trading partner
our trade represents
represents some 2.3 billion euros a day
most of our trade and goods and services
remains mutually beneficial but there is
an urgent need to rebalance our
relationship
on the basis of transparency
predictability and reciprocity
what we want is
China to respect the Level Playing Field
when it comes to access for our
companies to the Chinese market
to respect transparency about subsidies
to respect the intellectual property
and Beyond this we also know that there
are some areas where trade and
investment poses risks to our economic
and National Security
particularly in the context of China's
explicit Fusion of its Military and
Commercial sectors
and this is why
the central part of our future China
strategy must be economic de-risking
there are four areas for us to work on
which I want very briefly to touch on
the first is taking a critical look at
our own resilience and dependency and
making our own economy and Industry more
competitive and more resilient
and this is the work we have been doing
together you know it it began in the
investment in the green and the digital
through next Generation EU
to the pillars of our industrial policy
and the landmarked acts you know too
it's the chips act it is the critical
raw materials act and it's the Net Zero
industry Act
and leader signed up to it in Versailles
during the French presidency so now we
must keep strengthening our resilience
and sovereignty
in key areas you know them all it's
energy it's health and pharmaceutical
products it's food security but also of
course when it comes to our defense
capabilities
the second point is becoming Bolder and
better in using our existing trade
defense instruments
we have given ourselves the right tools
to deal with security concern and
economic distortions
so we must be more assertive
in using them when we need them
and I want to take this opportunity to
thank the parliament for its leadership
and agreeing on the new anti-coercion
instrument just a few weeks ago
the third element is the lead to look at
where we need to work on new tools
for some critical sectors
we need to ensure that our company's
capital
their expertise their knowledge
are not used to enhance the military and
intelligence capabilities of those
who also are our systemic Rivals that
cannot be
[Applause]
so we have to look at where there are
gaps in our toolbox
which allow the leakage of emerging and
sensitive Technologies through
investments in other countries
and this is why we're currently
reflecting on if
and how
Europe should develop an instrument on
outbound investment for very small
number but very sensitive Technologies
this will form part of a New Economic
Security strategy which the commission
will put forward in the coming months
the fourth principle is cooperation with
partners
whether on Economic Security on trade
whether with Partners we are close to in
the G7 or with those with whom we have
loser ties but some shared interests
this will be a core part of
diversification and the strengthening of
the resilience of our supply chains to
reduce our own vulnerabilities
honorable members
as the high representative said in 2019
the commission and the eeas collectively
proposed the Strategic update of our
China policy
since then the world has changed
enormously
China has changed Europe has changed
and that's why our European strategy has
to adapt to
a few weeks ago when I gave my speech on
China
I said
a strong European China policy relies on
strong coordination between member
states and EU institutions
and on the willingness
to avoid a divide and conquer tactics
that we know we may face
we have already in the recent days and
weeks seen those tactics in action
and it is now time for Europe to move to
action two now is the time to
demonstrate our Collective will
it is time to jointly Define what
success looks like and to show that
Unity that makes us so strong and in
this sense I say long live Europe thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much president from the
line now Mr Vapor please
the president secretary president
president of the commission
my representative
the way that we deal with China is the
central political issue of this decade
of the century
and by way of preparation I came across
a quote from Napoleon let China sleep
because when it wakes it will shake the
Earth
it's obvious that China is no longer
asleep China is waking up it's rousing
over the past decades in economic terms
it's tried to wake up but its economic
growth is not sufficient for it it wants
political influence since well it is
claiming political power across the
world
so it's good that today we are
discussing this topic as a prominent one
and I think we need to give a vote of
thanks to our president the commission
Ms fondeline has made a very clear
message on our behalf we need to respect
China as an important country in the
world but secondly there's a partnership
where it is in our mutual interests a
third
we need to work together to stop Putin
and that is a question on which we're
going to test it
China fourthly a strong partnership with
their American partners
defending our interests together with
the USA against China that's why I'd
like to thank Ms Honda line as the Epp
this is died in the mall Epp issue
Emmanuel macons also shown a great deal
of
positive action